hello and welcome to the new world
review where gone is a loser palmer's a
winner and kilauea didn't enter the race
because he was too scared he'd be
brushed aside
killa i need you to stop stalking gone
now please
palm you're a cutie you keep doing what
you're doing but maybe stop stabbing the
dolls though
episode 92 where we open this episode
was with the real protagonist of the ark
cult
cult listening to what's happening we
followed him very closely through
everything that happened and it was a
very status focused episode we've
discussed this before the way status
plays out in the show and
how the characters deal with being
better than or worse than others
this episode was very much about
pedestals pedestals and where characters
place
others it was less about their own
perceived status and more about the
status of those they perceived and
that's a very delicate difference that
i'm not sure i can describe any better
but i really enjoyed seeing it gone
realized he is a loser
compared to the others and that he
couldn't spend time moping about it how
bad it was because
others knuckle and that other guy coward
guy whose name i've forgotten
others would continue the fight on his
behalf they would save kite kite who was
given a memorial episode despite all the
characters in the scene between
gon and spin putting him on this
pedestal of power and empathy and light
and love
the art of kite in the sun looked very
much like he was walking toward the
light
that all they could see was his
silhouette because he was so bright and
magnificent there were no eyes
importantly we couldn't see his eyes and
that made sense because to see kite's
eyes is to know him to know his thoughts
to engage with him in the present when
we still know that he's dead
in any meaningful sense of the word the
empathy kite showed in episodes with
ghana and kilwa
and with the other members of the
annoying crew it showed his eyes because
the softening of eyes is the humanity of
kite
beheaded that humanity is now gone not
gone
no matter what we might see kite is no
longer that more
kite cannot be that but the silhouette
is bold enough a figure that if they see
it they will hesitate the power a person
has over another is directly related to
the power a person perceives them having
it's an emotionally dangerous place even
without anything else
it leaves everyone who cares about kite
open to emotional harm
again without even seeing him just
learning of his death meanwhile at the
start of the episode we had natero
deciding to do the empathic thing and
trying to save the queen from her
inevitable demise and
the most important thing about this is
the shirt naterro decided to wear
the pedestal was placed down for natero
to stand on with morel and
another guy getting intensely excited
about the idea that natera might
actually fight for real meanwhile
hetero's preparing his own pedestal to
hand over to the king
because he suspects correctly that the
king is going to be more powerful than
he is so he needs to find someone else
capable of more power than he is
in all of this i feel the tarot is the
most accurate with his pedestal placing
but since it's ultimately dependent on
colt's assessment maybe not with
everyone gone especially gone
saving the queen becomes a game of
futility she's too different to do
anything else and there was something
notable about the organ specialist
suggestion that cult pray two reasons
the first is that she treated him no
differently to how she would treat a
human suggesting that perhaps they could
live in harmony if you know
all of the bad ones just stopped the
other is that she's asking colt to pray
when the person he idolizes is in front
of her
the queen has been since colt's birth
rebirth
his return to life he's god she's his
god
everything he's done has been in service
to her we could talk about him as a
disciple and not be too far wrong
the problem is that colt deluded can't
handle her flaws
they're different organisms with
different value systems and colts tried
to hold to the old ways to protect his
mother
twice despite not being built to do so
and that opened a pandora's box of
problems one of which being that the
duty of a mother is a powerful thing in
this world
the queen had to die to preserve the
role of mothers to suffer and perish for
their sons but colt is not okay with
that expectation
he's a blend of the old world and the
new despite wanting to give
to her of himself he was willing to
sacrifice himself for her benefit and to
lie to her about the king which is
in itself heartbreaking the passing of
the gauntlet between generations and
now here is the hope at the bottom of
pandora's box
that weird little baby thing that came
out of the queen and
that's a serious problem isn't it what
if the king was supposed to be the soul
of his sister but was born prematurely
who did the queen leave behind you don't
just get lost in an ants organs are life
that's not
i mean it shouldn't it look this it i
don't also where did the octopus guy
with the beard come from was he a friend
of theirs do they just need an
extra old guy like is that just a thing
that's necessary like always have an old
guy nearby
and now that we have a name for the king
miriam the light that illuminates all
i have a strong expectation that we
bring illumi into all of this
because you can't call a character
illumi and not have him elume
something yes we know he's illumining
the curse in kilwa but i get the feeling
he can multitask maybe he should be
eluming more
speaking of multitasking this was the
first time it became explicit that not
only can the ants remember their
past lives but that they must have
discussed it at some point to know it's
a common experience
does this mean that as they begin to
spread across the world they decide to
mate with what they know
or that they'll mate with what they
don't the thing is at this point
i can see the corner being painted how
do you create such an invulnerable
natural phenomenon and not have the
series end because of its existence
put another way they will take over the
world they can
it's an unstoppable force nature is an
unstoppable force and when the point of
the unstoppable force
is simply to breed and grow ranks which
they can do very quickly
there's no reason they wouldn't be world
breaking and it adds to my lack of
understanding though it's been suggested
to me before that there is a way but it
hasn't been noted in the anime why we
haven't seen the scenario
play out before the only way i could
imagine it having played out is if
kilwa's family are in fact the remains
of an earlier generation of ants because
it would explain his strange blade hand
without nen situation
he's not human i've never really thought
he was but i don't know what
he is and that's the point since the
king wants some tasty food or to breed
because i'm not using any other word for
this we're somewhat pg right let's move
on to episode 93 to find out how he
hunts
and you know what episode 93 you to feel
bad for the king at the top of this
they're not going to be tasty or worthy
of his expensive palette
the decision to have the person in a
position of authority that he's headed
toward just be a kind of crappy person
puts a judgment call in our laps who is
more worthy of life and control of the
population
who deserves to be where they are
because he's right really isn't he
in the hands of an incompetent power
does bring nothing but
ruin there are times this show really
kicks me in the 2020 you know what
doesn't seem good is the shifting in
color of the king's men i
recognize that from dragon ball z when
characters get too powerful the basic
colors don't fit anymore
there's a color spectrum instead it's
interesting how quickly despite not
knowing how royalty works in the human
world magneto i
can't remember his name already um
something he follows the steps of
industry immediately we have a human
farm which makes a lot of sense but i
also
don't think he cared about the soldiers
enough to provide for them what's he
gonna do when he realizes they've all
struck out on their own to become kings
too in a very similar early pattern to
the one he just mocked
it's really interesting to me that
despite being so advanced they're also
very simple
because this behavior the striking out
to make your fortune happens in lions
and in humans without a power structure
but i don't know how far ahead they're
thinking
do they plan to mount a coup will they
try to get him to like them how are they
going to prove their strength worthiness
and power i guess
if they can keep the top half of their
bodies that would be a strong start but
still it's an interesting psychological
behavior for a colony of ants to take on
even if they are mixed with other
creatures and do they all benefit from
consuming men
if they can get it i know the rare
humans are tasty but the queen didn't
benefit from it so i'm interested to
learn
if it's something they can all gain not
just the king
speaking of which so many of them did
get an infusion
if he ate an ant with nen would he get
men from them
before i move on entirely from king
mahosaphat i do
need to mention his admittedly fair
point about pigs and cows
though it's odd where tagashi has
decided to leave information in
and where it's missing that specific
comment about whether we give mercy to
animals on the way to the slaughter
seems a lot like the writer rather than
the character having input it stood out
because it's an
odd level of knowledge for someone
without an understanding of how humans
live
the rest of this episode will be
dedicated to the cuteness of a love
triangle i mean
i don't even really want to go into the
discussion about gone being potentially
abused as a younger child because that's
what it would be i have no idea how old
palm is so i'm not going to comment on
that more than i am
right now uh let's focus instead on
kilwa's reaction to it all
qr manages to stalk them the whole day
he follows gone through all his planning
for a date he observes as gone has fun
with someone who's not him and he gently
reveals that jealousy straight through
the entire
montage his need to protect gone is a
self-driven
love thing if he thought clearly he'd
realized that palm is also an end user
or
at least we were led to believe that
since she's also an apprentice of one of
the other dude bras and that
he didn't need to be that close he
didn't need to watch the entire day he
can sense gone from further away than
that and it
seems that gone wanted to be on this
date he likes palm
despite her destruction of him hundreds
of times over hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of times over he recognized
that she was just disappointed and
needed to be treated well
it's actually frighteningly an example
of
good behavior he apologized
appropriately he told her he would do
something he failed and
he asked how he could make reparations
and then he followed through in earnest
it's the least psychopathic thing i've
seen him do and honestly it's quite
endearing
like the way he took kilwa on a date
when they ended up back home he
put care into the date he took palm on
and she's been very clear
this is the first date the first date
and she turned up to it with excitement
joadavir
and a certain je ne sais quois that
makes me wonder whose perspective we've
been seeing her at this whole time
because given how much of an affinity
gone's had with palm
i suspect how she arrived at the date is
exactly how he's seen her the whole time
and that terrifies the jealous kilwa
because it suggests that there will be a
second date
maybe if they survive a third who knows
not me
the sweetness of all this is the fact
that kilwa's realizing he doesn't have
the social experience
he didn't have the social experience
gone had growing up and that maybe he's
missed something as a person while not
being certain at all
he wants it of course it's not what he
wants though in what world would we
assume kilo was heterosexual
no he's not a fan of humans he's a fan
of god
and that's a very specific desire the
sad and concerning part of this is that
kilwa feels he has something to prove to
god and to himself and so now he's going
to take on bunny boy alone and that's
clear
in every step of protecting gone the day
before he was looking for escape
methods now he's being offensive because
he doesn't want to distract them from
their date but
more because he doesn't want gone to
come running i wonder whether in the end
his love of gone will win out or if the
curse will return
it would be very damning for his ego if
he not only fails to protect gone but
then
palm does i'm intrigued and i want to
know more and see
more and and more more more which is
great there are still episodes to watch
so i'll go do that and for now that's it
from me
if you enjoyed this dive into love
triangles and hope click here and here
and maybe here
make sure you're hydrating get yourself
some food and i'll see you
next time